I'm gonna do a big old twirl my name is
tak and I'm the designer for aria and I
like it and I've brought some beautiful
gowns with me today and I'm gonna turn
these guys into beautiful brides hi
everyone there's know a little bit of
our personalities well I'm married so my
wife has been through this before but I
wasn't there I really like fashioned
like a mini horse or a teacup pick is my
ring bearer and I want to look really
hot on my wedding to be very fun I like
things that are couture I wanted to be a
little quirky I'm Vin Diesel's probably
officiating I don't know if he's free
pretty classic guy I like to wear polo
shirts what I think of med I think of
that acid oh he's a business in the
front type guy he needs a party in the
back zach is cute as this is my day I
want all eyes on me keith is one of the
most exquisite beautiful creatures I
know I think he should have something
funky I want to look like Naomi Campbell
Eugene's gonna look prettier than any of
us let's just get it over with I think
I'm just adjust for your net all right
you're ready to try it on yeah of course
you're ready for it yes we've got a lot
of attention in this big ball guy oh
yeah very revealing look at that bosom
it's a high-fashion pose looks like
you're a hunchback that lower half is so
hairy oh it's so silky who's this
it is a petticoat I'm gonna be so fluffy
that just slid on like a globe Oh
tighten the back I would have to get
this dress altered as soon as you start
wearing that seeing your nipples becomes
weird literally spaghetti on my
shoulders hmm now you didn't tell us you
were pregnant
so is 1600 you the diamond
I feel like Big Bird but hot what is
this made out of chicken feathers
chicken feathers
oh don't fill it out coz there's a
mermaid cut you should never cut a
mermaid I feel like a princess
a hairy Jewish princess I can't move I'm
stuck those clamps you're like there's
something missing though I have just the
thing to complete your look for you oh
my god it's like a cape boys you ready
[Music]
looks great looks pretty decent yeah
[Music]
it's like the Walgreens they always have
that thing around Halloween is like was
that weird for you Ned I think Keith
looks more handsome than ever do you
Eugene take Keith to be your bride go
get it bro not the dress not the dress
not the dress got him I think it's
really nice to find a dress that matches
your personality it feels so pretty in
it it's a special day and you want to
find something that you feel special in
so I just think it's fun to hang out
with your friends and sort of like try
on some clothes together it's veil is
dig into my head but just like the way
that it makes me feel and all of the
emotions that the wedding day implies I
just feel so perfect and you
and I know that all of the Brides out
there who are getting married you're
going to be so perfect and beautiful I
can't wait for you to get me you should
lose five pounds though shut up
God Yugi I literally spot you I'm just
saying it would make you look perfect
god dammit here perfect but like five
pounds no no you would look like oh it
was a nice moment and you ruined I'd be
a very realistic bridesmaid you were
wrong